hi everyone alex gin here hope you're
all keeping well in today's video i'm
going to be going through some figure
eight spins both with the
short stick and the staff we'll be
looking at
ford figure eights as well as back with
figure eights
make sure you stick around to the end of
the video because i'll also be covering
some variations on these moves as well
okay let's get into it
[Music]
so to better understand figure eight
movements i'm going to show you a carly
stick first and then move
on to the staff later on from the front
profile if i take the stick from
side to side you can see it creates this
shape
where it's a circle on one side and then
a circle on the other side
when i'm doing these circles it creates
a figure eight pattern on its side
which is actually more like an infinity
sign
that's both the same for forwards or
backwards
from the side profile you can't really
see the figure eight as it just creates
circular movements both on the inside
and the outside so i'm going to start
side on with my arm
extended i rotate from my wrist
and if you notice my wrist is pointing
palm down to start with
from that position i rotate on the
inside so that's in front of me
from palm down to palm up
from this position i then rotate on the
outside behind me
so that's going to be from palm up back
to palm down and we're back to the
beginning again
if i repeat the process
there so i'm arm up going
palm down to palm up to palm down
and then you just keep going until it
becomes that fluid motion
with a stick sometimes it's hard to know
which orientation you should have with
your wrist
and where you should have the way should
turn it to
if you do the same with the blade it's
sometimes easier to understand
if in this position we're starting blade
down then you rotate the blade
and now it's going to be blade side up
i'm going to turn it again now it's
going to be blade down
blade up lay down
that'll be played up and that'll be laid
down
if you can visualize it like that it
helps a lot okay so how does this all
help learning to spin with the staff
with the joy you essentially do the same
movement you just focus on this end and
imagine that it's a carly staff
or sabre or any single-handed weapon for
example
and you just do the same movement where
you're starting from palm down
rotate it to palm up and then from palm
up
back to palm down the other thing that
you have to contend with the staff of
any kind
is this back end here and you've always
got to make sure that it's in the right
position
so from when i've got it palmed down i
want to make sure that it's on the
outside or behind me then when i rotate
it in front of me
see it's going behind me then i rotate
to palm up
now it's in front of me from this side i
let it
let it go forward as i take this behind
me it then goes back to palm down and
now it's behind me
so when my palm is down it's behind when
my palm is up
it's in front so when you're looking at
this front on you want to make sure that
you're shifting enough
so you're leaving enough space either
side so you're not hitting yourself
when this comes up or behind you
when that comes there as well you want
to make sure that you've got enough
space either side
you could either do this by moving your
arm fully across
like this but what i prefer to do is
actually
turn in my body and make it more body
movement
rather than just my arms that applies
both for forwards
and then for backwards as well
that's just something i've shown you on
the right side but you can also practice
on your left
going forwards and backwards
once you've got this moving you can also
practice it down by your hips
and above your head and even
across your body and then just try to
link all the movements together
i hope you found this useful if you did
please give the video a like and comment
down below
in the next video i'm gonna be covering
figure eights and transferring
from hand to hand both above and below
so that's it for this video until next
time take care and i'll see you soon
you